first let me just thank everyone there's
so many great ideas my brain is buzzing
with connections so I'm gonna actually
try and stick to my script here with a
hair and off on all different directions
so I'm gonna do a bit more reading than
I originally intended to do so the first
step in fixing a problem I think is
identifying a problem and science is a
couple we've talked about them today in
our small groups
there's the diversity problem the US
News and World Report recently noted
that the United States stem workforce is
no more diverse now than it was 14 years
ago so we're missing those insights and
talents from women and minorities and
those with disabilities they were still
not participating in stem studies or
careers there's also a lukewarm level of
trust in science in the United States
it's not getting worse though sometimes
people think that it's kind of staying
steady but according to a Pew Research
Center study only four in 10 people in
the United States report a great deal of
confidence in the scientific community
and it gets even more varied in terms of
response when you're talking about
issues such as climate science or
genetically modified food or energy
sources simple communication about
scientific facts is not the answer to
these issues Trust in particular is
challenging to build as facts rub up
against political or religious beliefs
which are ingrained in a person's
identity and a scientific identity is
exactly what we need to build if we hope
to have groups currently
underrepresented in the field study join
and persist in a stem career or simply
gain stem literacy this is where
conscious targeted outreach and
engagement to new audiences comes in now
this flash talk is not a place for a
doctoral dissertation around the subject
so I'm going to give some quick hits to
ideas which have informed the way we try
and address these issues at the Intrepid
Sea Air and Space Museum so first up we
let go of the idea that the scientist or
the science educator knows all and no
one else has anything to offer as was
referenced earlier too often the picture
that pops up when you ask someone to
think scientist
mail and often late so leveraging
indigenous knowledge has become part of
the conversation in STEM education and
some research relatively recently
indeed the National Museum of the
American Indian here in New York City if
you have a chance they have just opened
a new section on the math and science
practiced by Native American nations
historically it's very cool and very
hands-on and it's very free because it's
Smithsonian all the way downtown in our
work at the intrepid sea air and space
museum we think of using indigenous in
its meaning of occurring naturally
within a place rather than connecting to
a traditional culture so when working to
engage audiences with stem concepts
particularly youth and families through
our community engagement and youth
leadership programs we provide programs
in and/or recruit participants from high
need areas of the city we leave a lot of
room an opportunity for participants to
become the expert and to share what they
already know and understand to connect
to and show off the science behind their
interests talents and everyday practices
examples would be showing and sharing
food preparation techniques that involve
sophisticated understanding of the
fermentation process or chemical
reactions being behind hair and beauty
traditions it is essential if you want
participants to develop their identity
as people who engage with science daily
in a masterful way that you approach the
topics with respect encourage them to
take the lead and look at it as a
facilitated experience where we are all
learning together instead of an expert
in parting knowledge from on high to the
ignorant in short we're employing the
best practices of teaching and again I
would argue as Ben pointed out here that
science outreach can learn a lot from
pedagogy aside from making sure we're
going to where these audiences are
libraries community centers schools
public housing developments even prisons
when designing programs and experiences
we at the Museum spend a good deal of
thought on finding relevant entry points
based on interests of the target
audience and our individuals within that
audience and just as an aside to get
that like with NYCHA New York City
public housing complexes where we
developing community feedback groups so
again what they need what they want what
they understand what they're worried
about in terms of bringing their
families to the museum and how we can
use all those concerns and find those
relevant entry points so having programs
exploring the algorithms behind
something like Spotify or the way music
is produced mix and engineer and
recorded is a great way to engage music
obsessed teens for example connecting to
the familiar and the areas they feel
confident in and stretching their
thinking and experiences to new stem
concepts building scientific literacy
and once again a scientific identity
identifying these hooks and providing
connections from these interest-based
stem explorations to possible stem-based
careers is especially important for many
individuals from underrepresented groups
who may be the first in their family to
think about attending college when may
already be thinking about and working on
a practical level to contribute to
family support even as young as 13 or 14
well no one doubts that being a doctor
or dentist or research scientist is a
way to have an income medical schools a
long and costly process and challenging
to imagine is a path for a kid whose
schools didn't have advanced maths or
sciences and who at 16 isn't an A+
student in these areas these subjects
are generally taught completely divorced
from the world these students live in
sand they're not always successful at
them at first
technology is engaging and exciting but
we see there are challenges to
attracting and keeping individuals from
underrepresented groups particularly
women so one of the main things I think
we do well at the Museum for all
audiences but particularly for our goals
for girls program is provide
opportunities for them to meet and ask
questions of people who look like them
at different levels in their careers
with different career paths many of
which do not involve working alone in a
lab or 10 years of medical training or
any of these other things that they
imagine goes into being a scientist or
working in a stem field in the last year
we've had an array of career and
mentorship Day participants such as the
first black female astronaut in space
fabric engineers from coach chemists
from L'Oreal and a young woman whose
career has had her both
figuring out those algorithms for music
sales and touring as a drummer for the
artist m.i.a
best of all in our youth leadership
programs we work with our kids
explicitly on communication skills and
we hire them as paid interns or
eventually junior education staff when a
new family visits our museum or a
library where one of these staff members
is facilitating a program and see
someone who looks like them perhaps
speaking in their home language
facilitating an experience that explores
a complicated scientific concept I think
that does more to engage new audiences
and help create a scientific identity
among those who hadn't seen themselves
in that light before than anything else
we do so three minutes under and I am
done and while the mic goes to her I'm
gonna make a quick pitch we are working
on a year-long NSF grant to try and put
together methods for doing mid and
longitudinal studies of girls and stem
programs at museums and Science Center's
if anybody wants to play let me know
thanks for that talking - I'm a big fan
of your work
one of the questions that I continue to
kind of wrestle with and when you
mentioned putting scientists in front of
students who look like them is how we
continue to ask for volunteers or not
necessarily volunteers even paid
professionals to come in and give their
time and work to be the demonstration of
someone who looks like you can be a
scientist while at the same time not
asking that of typically their white
male peers so how do we continue to
justify using the time of current
scientists while leaving white males at
the bench to continue to pursue their
careers without interruption and how can
we balance that in a way that might be
beneficial to all parties that's a great
question and we don't leave them on the
bench we get them out for other things
for like public panels and things like
that so we definitely make use of them -
absolutely I think that for for the
women that we asked for particularly for
the goals program a lot of them are
coming from industry so unlike academia
they actually they get paid days to go
volunteer like that's part of the
structure of their environment and they
realize it was such a struggle for them
very much being the only girl or in
their coding class at school the only
woman in their college program or one of
five or something that this idea of
building a network with these young
women it's a ten year old program now so
it's nice it's got a whole sort of peer
network going on is is really at their
heart so I think it's something they
would do even if they weren't
compensated for it but it's much easier
for people who are not in academia
because academia doesn't always honor a
deeper work with towards tenure-track so
for the younger staff the younger
faculty it is difficult if you followed
them on Twitter in various other
communities where their response would
be how dare not ask us this is the work
that we that we understand that we're
supposed to be doing because we are at
this level and we understand what is
behind us and we have to pay it forward
many of the groups that we work with at
UNC Chapel Hill I'm one of those it's
the creator of the Twitter handle black
and stem that is part of her work who
she is when she takes on a postdoc
position is understood that I'm going to
be doing science outreach for this
purpose for this topic and so many
others in the community as well whether
we're talking about astrophysicists or
astronomers like Judea Eisler or Daniel
Lee some of those it is part of their
work and understood so I think they're
creating a culture where many many who
who are underrepresented scientists in
their field understand that this is part
of what what is required of us what is
needed to to change the landscape in the
future so I don't think for many of them
not saying all but it's not asking it's
not stretching saying that why leaving
out white males but it's saying that
this is work that we must we must do
I actually want to echo that because and
also say that for two years I did work
with the goals for girls at the intrepid
see so and I remember when I was
reaching out to a something I was a grad
student and I luckily had a PI who was
very generous with how often I really
needed to be in the lab and so for me it
wasn't necessarily am I going to get
paid to do this it was how can I not do
this and how can I actually expose
myself aid to these students but then
also to other individuals at the
intrepid so that I can get more
opportunities to do this because maybe
while you know white counterparts may be
the reason they can say no is because
they get asked all the time to do these
things and so for these opportunities I
took them as much as I could because I
saw it as paying it forward so I just
wanted to echo what you were saying cuz
I actually had a conversation with Jade
Ida about this very thing and that was
the thing that she said that she saw it
not as an extra thing but as an
extension of what she was already doing
oh I'll make this comment quick my
name's Tara Mac and LTI runs Skype a
scientist and one nice thing then when
we're like planning big scale outreach
events or programs one thing that we
focus on is making sure that the
minorities that we do have don't get
like quote-unquote wasted on white kids
so so like not so that we make sure that
we're making use of every person to
their best ability and when you're
planning one of these programs that are
huge that's something that you should
like just for all of us in the room to
like keep in mind and there are also a
lot of underrepresented groups in the
u.s. that a white dude is awesome for
like a rural community that wouldn't see
a scientist otherwise there and we never
don't want the white dudes participating
we absolutely do and we can use every
single one of them but we want to make
sure they're going to the right place
and if you have like big algorithms to
sort of help get people to where they're
best used that's really powerful
you